our next speaker is professor max
tegmark the other speakers I know them
for a long time but max I only met
recently but his famous so he doesn't
really need any introduction yeah the
only thing I'll say he's a physics
professor a cosmetologist and has
written a lot about many things and is
that founder of institutions thinking
very high things so max he called me a
cosmetologist which I'll take it as a
compliment sometimes I get they called
astrologer that'll serve them so it's a
great pleasure to be here and to see so
many familiar faces actually raise your
hand if you're an MIT student awesome
raise your hand if you're taking 80 to
electromagnetism right now whoo yeah
that's the course that that's the
dedication even only have to suffer
through hearing me torture them with
Maxwell's equations they still come out
on a Saturday so I have a little smiley
face here because this is even though
this is a very depressing feeling tough
subject I want to try it with a very
difficult task of injecting a little bit
of optimism in it first by just pointing
out that one of them may be the most
important thing we've discovered through
science is that our potential for the
future of humanity is just much more
awesome than we thought was before we're
stuck on some little planet now we
realize we're part of this grand cosmos
and we have the technology we're on the
verge of developing they can create a
future vastly grander than we have a
dreamt of you know so let's try to seize
that opportunity and I'll blow it in
some stupid way by nuking ourselves
moreover moreover there is another very
obvious source of optimism where the
things are awfully often we're better
than people often think there's so many
cool things you would love to do who
would like to improve the mbta here in
Boston raise your half yeah but oh it's
too expensive we can't afford it well
guess what there is we know because what
are you going to cut are you going to
cut health care there is something we
can save a lot of money on we've heard a
lot already about this trillion dollar
upgrade well Lucas Perry want to stand
up for exactly
he's he's a student here at bc he's
worked very hard i'm making this little
trillion dollar gift card shopping cart
app you can share it with your friends
when we launched it this later this
month and you can go in and you can
click on upgrading mbta opes
1,000,000,000 still have 999 to spare
and you can and then you can maybe raise
the salaries of give a thousand ten
thousand dollar bonus maybe to everybody
in the Armed Forces still a tiny
fraction of the money maybe you want to
build high-speed rail maybe you want to
improve education maybe you want to
there's so much stuff you can do what
you find when you play with this is
trillion dollars really goes a long way
continuing on the uplifting spirit
there's something I want to celebrate
today so today is the 88th birthday of
the guy you see here who wrote the first
ever really comprehensive article on the
hydrogen bomb the early Hydra bomb
testing and the problems at this cause
in he wrote this in 1954 and to
celebrate this we published this this
morning on our future of life org
website fascinating reading feels very
very timely actually he wrote this
article under the name jewel Laura which
is a pseudonym because he was worried
about the McCarthy gang coming coming
after him but I happen to know who it
was and yes where he did his PhD MIP
right here just a couple of years
earlier in the math department course
two in fact and one more little thing I
can tell you about is it's my dad happy
birthday daddy Harold cefiro yeah
he Lindsay he's in the hospital right
now it's kind of tough time for him so I
think it's going to be very happy when I
bet when I tell him that the your water
for him and if you read his article and
he'll be even happier now this was
nineteen fifty four two years later
these were all the American nuclear
targets that we had this was recently
Declassified with a future of life
Institute one of the things we're trying
very hard to do is to make it easier for
everybody to share this sort of
information and then really appreciate
what it means so if you tell someone
well a thousand or fourteen thousand
nuclear weapons what's that it's a big
number but when you see a lot of
thoughts like this on a map to me it has
a whole different sort of connotation
and if you have a phone which I know you
all have take it out go to future of
life org or one word and if you if you
when you go there you will be greeted by
a website which looks like this coming
soon to a screen near you and if you
just click new king who he'll come for
this this thing and you'll find the tech
we've spent a lot of time in the run-up
to this conference to create a series of
interactive apps you can go here and you
can see ok let's look at my look at them
what was targeted exactly Oh surprising
China was targeted China didn't have
nukes then but apparently they were
targeted anyway and actually quite a bit
let's see if we can find some big city
here maybe Shanghai or maybe Beijing and
then you can click on you zoom in a
little bit let's go to take a closer
look Oh Beijing has a lot of nuclear
targets let's try this one actually this
looks like a little bit off-center try
baby done and then you can click
detonate if you're feeling a little bit
morbid and when you do that you come to
nuke map raise your hand if you know
about nuke map okay Alex wellerstein you
want to stand up where are you he made
me mad
AA and and then you can you can click
and you can see what happens and and
then you can try different sized bombs
and you can go anywhere else in the
world we basically want to make it
easier for people to translate these
abstract ideas into what what it really
means and then you can ask yourself of
course how many nuclear weapons do we
actually mean to have really good
deterrence that was a thousand roughly
you saw then now the US has about 7,000
including the ones that are slated for
retirement a lot of other countries have
determined you need about two hundred
some feel you need even less it's very
important conversation to have it we'll
talk more about that my feeling is you
don't eat as many as 7,000 I think you
had suppressed the pretty hard to refute
the argument now the other people then
they're people who say well okay we have
all these nukes so why should we worry
about them I mean no one in the right
mind would would start an all-out
nuclear war but we heard from Lisbeth
that the may be the greatest risk of
many of the greatest military threat to
the US is not a deliberate nuclear
attack on us but an accidental nuclear
war and raised so you can ask you a quiz
question it's a bad habit we professors
have here who is more famous of these
guys
let me ask you a second question which
one of these two guys do we have to
thank for the fact that we're all alive
and well here because he single-handedly
stopped the Soviet nuclear attack during
the Cuban Missile Crisis I'm giving you
one hint she's not Canadian all right
and again you know just to drive this
home a little bit we have made another
app for that re alcon you want to stand
up she's she is our website basically
this is arielle flew in from Colorado
thank you see if you come back to our
main page here again you go and click on
on the near misses there's a timeline of
approximately 25 things so we took stuff
those in Eric's clashes book and from
all the other sources and a couple of
things and just try to make it very
easily accessible so you can share you
with your friends and and the bottom
line is there isn't just one or two with
three things we've heard a very specific
examples from from this bet which were
very scary the arkhipov one was pretty
amazing because it happened during the
Cuban Missile Crisis with which William
Perry is very personally familiar with
and but it goes on and on and on and
some of them both things are even pretty
recent and it's also quite obvious that
there is a publication bias here because
most of these are from the US I have no
reason to think that this the Soviet and
Russian systems failed less and have
fewer false alarm and there's also
strong selection bias towards things
long ago that have been Declassified so
there's undoubtedly a lot more and you
all know of course that if you just keep
rolling the dice for a long long for a
large number of times eventually you
know your luck does run out we physics
nerds know that if you take am it's just
like you have a radioactive atom with a
half-life every year maybe it's only 1%
chance but then the probability that
you're going to go for a really long
time without a nuclear war drops
exponentially so the question isn't if
we're going to have an accidental
luthier but just how long it's going to
take so relying a look not the greatest
strategy what do we do about this what's
our goal
it's been fascinating this morning to
listen to the talks it's clear that
there is a wide range of opinions about
what we should do even within this room
there are some who feel strongly we
should get rid of all nuclear weapons
there's some who feel we should simply
reduce our Arsenal's there are also
people especially people not in this
room who would instead like this
increase their nuclear arsenals upgrade
so on so but I think the really
interesting point about this is it's not
so it's kind of a waste of time to argue
enormously about the end goals whether
you want to end up there or there if you
or like we all agree that we want to go
to the left on this rather them closer
to the cliff here so the first step
should obviously be less for example not
spend a trillion dollars upgrading
irrational what can you do about that
can do a lot of things we have more
power than we think you have power not
only when you vote and when you tweet
and when you share with your friends
some of the all of these online tools
and things that exist you have power
when you shop if you're choosing between
a Honeywell air conditioner and a
general electric air conditioner you can
factor in your free to factor in it's a
free country the fact the General
Electric decided to get out of the
nuclear weapons business honeywell spill
in and when you invest you have a lot of
power raise your hand if you have a
retirement fund or any kind of mutual
fund okay those of you who didn't raise
your hand you have parents they probably
do they have the right to change most
people even some very this hardcore
activists who would like to reduce the
nuclear arsenals have confessed to me
that they probably also are invested in
nuclear weapons production so we decided
to make things a little bit easier for
them Stephen Hawking our physics
colleague good friend of ours he wasn't
able to come here today very hard from
the trouble but he did send us a special
message he said if you don't want if you
want to slow the nuclear arms race then
put your money where your mouth is don't
Bank on the bomb so we're going to hear
more specifics about that from Susie
Snyder but we there's an app for that as
well and I want to end my talk by just
showing you that you can simply go back
to the main page again and click on that
on the Stephen Hawking I
and you get this lap it works on your
phone too we don't tell you what you
should care about you tell the app you
can say I care about land mines or I
don't care about land mines you care but
news whatever you take you to care about
it'll tell you okay here are the
companies that make him if you want to
know my goodness that's weird why is why
is Airbus on there you click it tells
you and and then if you have mutual
funds me it's kind of hard to tell
whether your mutual fund if it's a
nested Vanguard S&P 500 or whatever is
invested in oops well we make it easy
for you to go in here maybe you have
tiaa-cref maybe or you want to be
socially responsible maybe you have
money in the PA crafts social choice act
equity fund oops take on a sad face a
red face why oh they actually have
investments in floor and jacobs
engineering you know and it's a free
country nobody you can't don't have the
right let's say i'm not going to pay
taxes that you have to do but you have
the right to invest in whatever you want
and if you don't want to invest in that
fun well we have links to all the smiley
faced one here which you can move on
average give you just as much profit and
you can feel better about it so in
summary yes this is very serious set of
problems but don't feel powerless and
disempowered feeling that you have to
wait and let just hope that Donald Trump
is going to solve all your problems
because actually there's a lot of things
you can do right now without even
waiting for politicians and we've given
a whole bunch of examples here we're
going to hear a lot more later in the
day and there's even going to be some
very exciting announcements later in the
afternoon about this so thank you so so
much